these men are among some 100 survivors
of the Shipwreck they're being
temporarily sheltered in a warehouse on
the Kalamata docks in southern Greece
Aid workers told us some fainted when
they were brought onshore and were in a
State of Shock it's likely that they
have loved ones who didn't survive the
boat sinking
we got the call about a shipwreck at 4am
and the coast guard told us there were
700 people on board we thought that was
exaggerated but apparently it wasn't the
survivors here said that the women and
children were below the decks and it
seems they suffered the worst effects of
the capsizing
Coast Guard says the trawler was spotted
heading for Italy on Tuesday morning and
asked only for food and water as It sped
North but in the small hours of
Wednesday as a Hellenic Coast Guard
vessel sailed alongside it its engines
stopped working the captain of the Greek
Coast Guard vessel said the boat lurched
side to side so violently that it
capsized and sank in 15 minutes possibly
the result of panic on the overcrowded
boat
Greece's caretaker government has
declared three days of mourning but some
here say that politics have played a big
part in the tragedy the Aegean has
become a highly tense area ever since
turkey said in March of 2020 that it was
no longer going to prevent Asylum
Seekers from reaching Greek Islands and
the Greek Coast Guard and Border guard
have been on high alert to prevent them
from doing so many human traffickers
have chosen the long-haul Mediterranean
route either from Turkish Shores or from
North African Shores directly to Italy
using larger vessels carrying hundreds
of people and the numbers speak for
themselves some six and a half thousand
people have reached Greece across the
sea so far this year according to the
United Nations but some 54 000 have
reached Italy
this lady was one of many local
residents who brought clothes she was
turned away no women's clothes were
needed said the aid worker nor
children's because none of them survived
John saropoulos Al Jazeera Kalamata
David yambio was once a migrant who made
the dangerous Journey from Libya to
Italy he is now an activist and
spokesman for refugees in Libya he says
the situation for Asylum seekers in
Libya is desperate
having the right to be protected in
Libya and then I don't receive this
protection because through this
mechanism there is a kind of a network
which benefits from my from my body by
detailing Me by putting me into slave
level by exploiting my family uh given
this situation so when we mention EU
officials traveling to Libya talking
about different kind of agreement with
the state not being able to visit these
detention centers to see how overcrowded
it is because uh I for so many times 17
times that I was arbitally detained in
Libya just because I was an asylum
Seeker being Rebel has illegal immigrant
or immediately put under the category of
trying to cross the Mediterranean so I
was in in prison for so many times and
constantly in these places I was subject
to slavery because when I have to work
for three consecutive months without
being paid without being provided the
necessary you know or human basic needs
we are talking about you know being
hindered from accessing food to clean
drinking water this is something that
European people cannot stay away from in
the morning I know they drink a lot of
water since they wake up and they have
good sleep being hindered from being
able to sleep a child who is just newly
born and then put you know in a
suffocating room where they have to
endure uh severe uh degrading human
violations so we are speaking in this
perspective that is why we say the EU
authorities Industries are not looking
to find alternatives for this situation
because no one really want to migrate
using this journey